two years ago today three white men
chased down and murdered ahmad aarberry
that is not in dispute and now neither
is their motivation the family of arbury
is still mourning the loss but now
they're also celebrating a victory in
federal court travis mcmichael his
father gregory and their neighbor
william roddy bryan were convicted of
hate crimes these cases are very rare
and notoriously difficult for the
justice department to pursue
but the prosecution succeeded in finding
evidence that the defendants had a
history of racism and acted on it janet
chamblin spoke to arbory's mother after
yesterday's verdict
when are the hardest moments for you
wanda waking up every morning
knowing that ahmad is gone
and he's not going to be here today like
he wasn't here yesterday
wanda cooper jones knows tuesday's
verdict will never bring her son back
but that doesn't mean it wasn't welcome
news why was this federal trial
important to you
the world knew that ahmad was murdered
however the world needed to know
the mindsets of the men that who
actually murdered the mod and that these
guys were racist
was murdered simply because he was a he
was a black man
it was the second time in three months
the ivory family and legal team won
their fight as gregory and travis
mcmichael and william roddy bryan were
found guilty
all three now face life in prison for
federal hate crimes in addition to their
life sentences for their murder
convictions attorney general merrick
garland praised the ruling i cannot
imagine the pain that a mother
feels
to have her son
run down and then gunned down
while taking a jog on a public street
wanda cooper jones plans to keep that
fight going in honor of her son
this is a burden you've been carrying
for two years now are you able to
continue to fight for the change that
you want to see happen or are you spent
i must continue to fight like i should
earlier i don't think a mother should go
through the heartbreak that i've been
through the last two years for cbs
mornings i'm janet schamelian in
brunswick georgia